this is didi diddy was the darling tech
company in china it's basically china's
version of uber and it was hailed as the
company that drove uber and the evil
americans out of china didi was a symbol
of chinese pride and innovation and back
in 2020 didi was doing better than ever
before didi was a favorite of the
chinese communist party or ccp and with
that favoritism came some nice
preferential treatment
money was rolling in and they were
planning on expanding globally
everything was going better than they
could have ever dreamed of but on the
turn of a dime everything changed
somewhere somehow the ccp's opinion of
dd changed and within the space of a few
months the company's revenue and future
crashed straight into the ground they
started hemorrhaging money their apps
were banned in china and no matter how
much the dd executives pleaded and
begged the ccp kept tightening the noose
around them and in just one year didi
lost over 60 billion dollars that's 80
of what the entire company was worth it
had to fire thousands of employees cut
back on its expansion plans but nothing
worked what happened to dede was a
painful lesson in china no matter how
rich no matter how successful no matter
how powerful you think you may be as a
businessman you are still the ccp's
female dog you still have to answer to
their every beck and call and when
they're done with you all your success
all your hard work will go down the
drain because the same hand that feeds
you will gladly let you starve
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime on my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
all you have to do is follow me on
instagram at jaketran and you're
automatically entered a few of you have
won already watch out for fake accounts
i will never message you asking for
money or to invest and this is why you
never want to be a businessman in china
[Music]
any successful entrepreneur knows that
starting a company like dd takes a lot
of hard work and skill you have to know
selling marketing branding operations
leadership and much more and you used to
have to pay a lot of money for
university to learn this stuff or you
had to search the internet to learn from
unreliable sources but not anymore
because that is where skillshare comes
in skillshare is an online learning
community where you can explore your
passions with thousands of different
courses the people who make the most
money in the world are the ones with the
best skills
and with skillshare you can learn all
those skills on demand no matter what
subjects you want to learn you can find
them on skillshare there are just so
many valuable and interesting courses on
there like youtube success scripts shoot
and edit by the giant tech youtuber
marcus brownlee or ecommerce for
creatives sell your artwork with an
online store which is another really
cool one i recommend starting with
productivity masterclass by youtuber ali
abdal it will give you super useful
advice to boost your productivity
permanently so you can tackle all your
goals there are a ton of experts
teaching on skillshare who are
constantly putting out new fascinating
courses and you'll never be distracted
by ads or interruptions while you learn
plus the entire course catalog is now
available with subtitles in spanish
french portuguese and german and the
first 1000 people to pause the video and
click the link below will get a one
month free trial of skillshare so pause
the video and click the link below right
now to start exploring your creativity
on skillshare today thanks to skillshare
for sponsoring this video
[Music]
after eight years of working for alibaba
chinese entrepreneur chiang wai decided
to start dd back in 2012. the business
started out as a simple app that let
users request taxis or ride shares in
privately owned cars and just like uber
it became a massive success it was a
simple cost-effective convenient app
that anyone could use pretty soon dd was
growing faster than any of its
executives could have imagined investors
jumped at the chance to get in on such a
promising business and chengwei didi's
founder had some pretty big ideas for
the company's future first on his list
was getting rid of the competition on
his home turf which included uber
to do that didi would need to get as
many users on its app as possible it
would need to steal as many of uber's
customers as possible and hopefully that
would make uber realize fighting to stay
in china wasn't worth it and it led to a
price war for months uber and didi were
in a discount deadlock both apps were
offering their users insane discounts on
trips in the hopes of attracting the
most customers but in the end dd came
out on top it managed to break in
billions of dollars in investments from
companies like apple alibaba and tencent
but the real game changer was a little
two billion dollar investment from the
ccp's piggy bank from what's called the
china investment corporation also known
as china's sovereign wealth fund two
billion dollars
imagine if you were going up against a
competitor and your government gave you
two billion dollars to outspend them
your competitor wouldn't stand a chance
you would simply run their bank account
into the ground wipe them out and then
be left with a monopoly and that's
exactly what didi did to uber in china
ddb uber not because didi's business
model was inherently better than ubers
they didn't beat uber based on merit no
ddb uber because the ccp wanted them to
the ccp gave didi a monopoly and made
all their dreams come true uber admitted
defeat in mid-2016 and dd bought them
out for 1 billion
and dd proceeded to become the hottest
tech company on the block and everyone
wanted in on the billions it was so
obviously going to make but what goes up
fast will fall down even faster
[Music]
for dd's executives dominating china's
e-healing industry wasn't enough they
started getting greedy high on its local
success they wanted to expand across the
whole world to start giving uber a real
run for its money the ccp loved dd its
users loved all the apps extra services
like ordering ride shares instead of
regular taxis or privately driven
vehicles didi obviously had a real
chance of taking over the international
market and with the chinese government
offering its full support what could
possibly go wrong
the only issue dd had with global
expansion was money if it was going to
start operating in europe the americas
and the rest of asia it was going to
need some serious cash
more than apple alibaba or the
government was willing to offer and
there was only one way to get that kind
of financing in the space of a few weeks
take dd public
by listing the company on a stock
exchange people would be able to buy
stock in the company and didi would be
able to use that money to make all its
global domination dreams come true
obviously the best stock exchange for
the job would be in america no asian
stock market would ever allow them to
raise the kind of money they needed so
in 2021 dd announced its plans to get
listed on the new york stock exchange or
nyse
grave mistake almost immediately the ccp
sent word to dd executives telling them
not to go forward with their plans
because of security concerns but the dd
executives weren't having it this is
their company after all why should they
listen to the ccp this will be good for
spreading china's legacy across the
world so foolishly dd pushed forward
[Music]
the ccp is a notoriously hot-headed
indecisive political party one day one
government official is telling companies
to stop their operations the next
someone else is telling them to push
forward faster than ever before because
of that most chinese tech companies
prefer to act now and apologize later
meaning they generally ignore the less
serious government warnings and
statements do what they want and then
hope the ccp forgives them once the dust
settles that's how it has always worked
in china and that's exactly what dd
expected would happen with their ipo the
ccp's warning was just another example
of the government's indecision in their
minds dd would go public make billions
from selling stocks and the ccp would
have no choice but to back them and
forget all about its earlier warnings at
least that was the plan
so instead of following the ccp's
warning didi went ahead and enlisted its
stocks on the new york stock exchange on
june 30th 2021.
in just the first few days of its ipo
didi managed to raise 4.4 billion
dollars bringing the company's official
value up to 70 billion dollars
that's about the size of airbnb or
target
dd's nyse debut was the biggest any
chinese company had achieved in new york
besides alibaba and for a few short days
it looked like didi had actually managed
to pull the ipo off without angering the
ccp didi was set to become one of
china's biggest successes yet and then
the ccp slapped didi with a major
reality check
[Music]
contrary to a dd expected it turned out
this ccp had taken quite a lot of
offense at the way the company had
disobeyed them just two days after
listing on the nyse the cyberspace
administration of china or cac announced
an investigation into didi on the
grounds of protecting national security
no one in the company had seen it coming
another two days later and the cac
officially bans the dd app from china's
app store and blocks any new users from
signing up
according to the cac didi had been
collecting sensitive information on its
chinese users for years if american
companies and billionaires could buy
controlling stocks in the company or
request audits or request information on
the behind-the-scenes operations of dd
that would put millions of chinese
citizens in danger of being spied on or
having their information stolen by a
foreign adversary
kinda like what china probably does with
tick-tock
and for the ccp that was a bridge too
far they gave didi everything and now it
was time to take it all away
no matter what dd tried to appease the
cac and prove that its security was
airtight they just wouldn't budge
they even scrapped their expansion plans
completely but nothing seemed to make a
difference and meanwhile less than a
week after listing on the nyse dd's
stock prices were already down by almost
20 percent
something had to be done or it would be
the end of the company but the only way
the ccp would let dd start operating
again in china would be to de-list from
the new york stock exchange
and doing that so soon after just ipoint
was almost unheard of but by december
2021 dd's options had run out
on december 3rd 2021 almost six months
after going public dd announced its
plans to de-list from the new york stock
exchange
may 23rd to vote on d-listing from the
new york stock exchange while
simultaneously listing its stock on the
hong kong stock exchange
didi hoped that hong kong would be close
enough to home for the cac to stop
breathing down their necks
but nothing seemed to be enough for the
ccp by then didi had lost nearly 60
billion dollars in just 11 months equal
to 80 percent of the company's entire
worth
the company was practically destroyed
and to make matters worse even the hong
kong listing had to be put on hold while
didi officially delisted from new york
[Music]
[Music]
what happened to didi was the ccp's way
of teaching china's tech industry a very
important lesson
you live breathe and succeed at the
pleasure of the party we decide if you
make it and we decide if we want to bury
you
after a year of the cac making life hell
for dede the cac investigators finally
came up with a punishment a 1.2 billion
dollar fine plus small fines for both
dd's executives and that's on top of the
decimation of their company's value
this time dede seemed to have gotten the
memo and quickly accepted the verdict
saying it would do everything in its
power to quote rectify its wrongdoings
end quote and although dede can slowly
start getting back to business it's
unlikely the company will ever be as big
as it once was
so what's the lesson from this well
there's a few
one don't let success go to your head
especially when all your success was
subsidized by someone else which brings
us to number two despise the free lunch
the ccp makes the american government
look like weak little pigs but the
american government can be pretty
ruthless too for nearly a decade
starting in 2001 the cia kidnapped
hundreds of suspected arabic suspects to
question using brutal bloodthirsty
enhanced interrogation techniques
they didn't care that lots of the men
and women they were questioning were
actually innocent or that the things
they were doing to their prisoners were
completely illegal
and this practice of illegally detaining
people in secret prisons around the
world became known as the cia's black
site program
and honestly the stuff the cia officers
did to their prisoners was despicable
and it's probably the darkest most
sinister topic we've ever covered on
this channel
but obviously a deep dive into all the
creative ways the cia found to break
their prisoners would set off a million
red flags and get any public video
instantly demonetized by youtube
that's why to share every last
horrifying detail with you we've had to
release it as a full-length private
documentary available only to members of
this channel and all you have to do to
get access to this exclusive documentary
right now along with other full-length
videos on topics like the roots of
middle eastern terror every gepstein
mkultra the cia's mind control program
is click that join button below people
pay tens of thousands of dollars to
attend university and leave still not
knowing anything about how the world
really works
but by becoming a member you'll get
access to all this insider info for only
five dollars a month and trust us it's
way more entertaining than university
lectures
plus there's a refund policy too unlike
most youtube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
and we will personally refund you for
your first month after your first month
there is no refund
[Music]
we haven't done a china video in a while
so i'm really happy with how this one
came out so let me know what you thought
in the comments below and if you're new
here this is one of the biggest channels
on youtube for documentaries on money
power war and crime we make multiple
videos just like this one every single
week so click that subscribe button
below you can follow me on instagram
jaketran but that's gonna wrap it up
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you